this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
hello everyone welcome to our last
people computer and design seminar for
fall I hope all of you have a great
break coming up we're gonna resume on
January 11th with URI but let's go Vic
who's going to talk about his research
here on social networks and today we
have Joe fish kay I've known Joe fish
for a number of years and my favorite
anecdote about Joe fish is he has the
best research project name that I've
ever heard and one of my goals in life
is to be able to match that and he was a
PhD student at the MIT Media Lab where
he worked among other things on kitchen
research kitchen technology and the name
for their kitchen of the future project
was called coming up with a smart
kitchen it was called counter
intelligence I love it
and since then Joe fish has done a whole
bunch of things he went on and actually
got his PhD from Cornell working with
Phoebe singers there and it's done a
whole bunch of things including
ethnographic research on how families
use technology and he's done a great job
of connecting the human side of things
through longitudinal studies with the
technical side of things and today he's
going to tell us about a bunch of his
research on tablets pleasure to be here
thank you all for coming
I realize coming to lectures at the end
of the semester for at least those of
you that are students is you know can
get more optional those things going on
so I'm delighted to have you here I'm
also delighted to be back in this for
mine I someone asked about this know
when to look back so I last gave a talk
this five years ago so I figure if I
come back every five years that's kind
of a nice ratio I like this so I want to
talk about some work that I have done
and I want to particularly mention that
this is work that I've done with Rachel
Hinman and we'll talk more about the
context in which this particular work
happened what I wanted but she's sort of
a co-author on this stuff so this is me
I am a senior research scientist at
Yahoo in the human-computer interaction
research group there as Scott mentioned
I have some degree
from hanging around various institutions
on these coasts - I've been teaching
here slightly more recently with Terry
we've been teaching the designing
liberation technology class in the last
year I've coached it a couple of years
before that and I'm also a father of
twins and I'm fortunate I couldn't find
a really nice picture of me with the
twins but this is me with one of the
twins and the other one looks like that
so you've seen a Kwan you see you know
you know this one right so what I want
to talk about here this is this is a
this is a talk that I want to divide
into two parts right the first part is
the stuff that I actually know about
right and that's the findings that we
found from this study of iPad users and
then the second part is the implications
of that study and I think that's the bit
that's a little bit more interesting
it's a little bit more provocative and
it's a little bit more on shaky ground
as in I'm sort of pulling stuff out with
sort of very weak signals so hopefully
we'll have some time afterwards for a
discussion and for talking about this
kind of stuff um
this page is legalese this points out
that this is work that I did when I was
working at Nokia this is not work that
is based on work I've been doing at
Yahoo so what you see here does not
reflect the opinion of Yahoo on any
stuff right you don't need to run out
and be like oh yeah who's gonna make a
tablet tomorrow because I didn't say
that line right it is in work that I did
with Rachel Hindman who's now at Intel
um and it is based on published stuff
from Nokia so this isn't me sort of
taking secrets away from Nokia's his
stuff that I publish when I was there so
boring legalese over anyone recognized
this guy yeah so this is Mark Weiser he
it is wiser right I have this you know
you have these primary things that I've
always think that it might be Weiser I
and I've known this but I still get
doing so what was talking about three
particular things one in his ubiquitous
computing stuff he was talking about
computing at three scales it was talking
about computing at the inch scale at the
foot scale and at the yard scale and the
back then they had to go and build
devices that would work to function to
do computing at the inter scale on the
foot scale in the yard scale so they did
the park tab and the park pad
and the live board and all of these were
devices for exploring these different
scales of computing and one of the
things that I think is interesting is to
take a step back and I'm going to
particularly go back and have a look at
the Scientific American article on this
we've now got a lot of this inch foot
and yard scale except that the inch
scale is happening at the phone and the
odd scale is happening and the foot
scale is happening at the tablet is the
tablet and we're seeing big TVs taking
up the space of the yard scale and
that's a sort of interesting thing to
look at how that's worked out and how
that's played out and within that
context I want to talk about the foot
scale I want to talk about that well how
how the tablet is played out so the
field study that this is based on was
done about eighteen months ago and what
we did was we wanted to find people
using iPads in the San Francisco Bay
Area this is very much a convenient
sample right this wasn't us trying to
get a sort of representative sample of
anything we wanted to get diversity we
wanted to get people that were diverse
in age diverse in in occupations we
didn't what just want to get nerds and
then we would go to their homes and we'd
hang out with them and we'd spend a
whole bunch of time talking to them and
asking questions and we do things like
get tours of their homes with and we'd
say well tell us about your routine and
we'd sort of walk around their room like
well like I wake up in the morning and I
and I before I get out of bed I grab my
tablet and I check my email so we go up
to their room and sort of look at where
they where they kept their tablet and
things like that so we got within the
boundaries of an interview study a
pretty rich story about what what was
going on we wanted we then did some
analysis on this and there are many ways
in which we did this analysis we did
lots of watching the videos again we
took notes in all manners all different
ways we did a lot of affinity analysis
and clustering and things like that
and I also want to point out that
racially I'm pretty good at making sense
of this data so I think we did less
formal work than some people do like we
didn't put stuff into at this ti or
something like that but I think the
results are reasonably solid so let's
talk about what we found out of this
research one of the things we found was
that people bought it for the sheer hell
of it people bought iPads because they
wanted to buy iPads they didn't buy
iPads because they had a problem that
were trying to solve right it was the
sort of this shiny beautiful object and
people really liked them right people
sort of took great joy and they are
gorgeous objects I mean they're so
pretty at the same time people bought it
then they were like well I'm not quite
sure what I'm gonna do with it right and
we found people like like like Indrani
he said well I got an iPad and I was
really excited by it about for the first
month and I haven't opened it for the
last two months like okay that's kind of
interesting so this wasn't a huge sample
it wasn't like we we sort of went
digging around trying to find everybody
who might possibly had any experience
and there were a couple of other people
who said yeah well we haven't really
used it this week or something it would
be under magazines things like that and
people this guy Daniel was like well
I've got it but I I'm 19% the time I go
back to my laptop and this was
interesting cuz this wasn't the story we
were hearing sort of in the popular
press or it was like old tablets are
gonna take over everything it's the
future one of the other things that we
found was this interesting thing which
tablets didn't weren't quite so
individualized as of a lot of what we
had seen with laptops laptops had a
clear owner like this is my laptop
occasionally someone might use someone
else's if you're you're in the kitchen
and it's there and you need to look up
something but laptops seem to have this
much stronger sense of ownership than
the than tablets did at the same time
there were some interesting things like
tablets are not very well designed for
multiple users there is there's not a
very good way for example to have even
basic email security at many
corporations you can check your email
you know you'll have an exchange email
client or something right so it's great
because on the on my wife's iPad I could
install I could have my Nokia email and
I could read it on the iPad problem was
that Nokia said well if you want to read
any device you you read out your email
has got to have a five digit PIN number
so okay so that five digit PIN number
from is then my wife needs to know the
five digit PIN number to use her iPad
and once we're once anyone's using it or
if someone's to borrow a web browser or
something once they're using it there's
no further authentification like okay
that's kind of a problem right thinking
about the right ways to do this so we'll
talk a bit more about that later
one of the other things we found that
was a quite fundamental difference
really was about the difference
different kinds of ways that people's
bodies were arranged when they were
using these tablets people use tablet
people use laptops on the couch right
everyone knows you sit on the couch you
watching TV you've got your laptop in
front of you and that's great but we saw
the extent that we saw this for tablets
was far more than anything I had seen
elsewhere but the fact that people
really were lying in bed reading them
and one of the ways that one thing is
the fascinating view of the people would
not only lie in bed and watch movies on
their tablet but they would do it when
they had sort of a big impressive stereo
system right you know they had a 48 inch
TV with black and Bose and quad Rove
surround and yet they'll go on watch
their movie in bed cuddled up and
there's something really interesting
about that this was as I said about 18
months ago that most of this research
was done and one of the things that most
of this field study was done sorry
there was a lot of question about what
the role of the 3G and iPads right so
whether you basically whether you had a
Wi-Fi iPad or whether you didn't and we
found that that there was some effects
right we found that for example there
were people if you had if you had the
one with the with the with the sim in it
you were more likely to use it out of
the house like that was a pretty that
was a pretty strong result at the same
time there was some interesting edge
cases so I think this quote down here
from Angela Angela lives in Silicon
Valley down in Mountain View she's
married to someone who works at Cisco
they've got three kids nice family and
she said well I've tried making a
grocery list on the iPad because that
seemed like a reasonable thing to do and
then she got to the got to Safeway and
sort of got the iPad out and she felt
horrible she was like oh my god this is
really embarrassing like walking around
Safeway with this with this
I've had grocery lists and I thought
that was interesting right when people
tell you that story when people talk
about and partly it's sort of you know
at the time it was quite an expensive
object it's still quite an expensive
object it was but she felt this phrase
shame great shame and embarrassment and
when people say things like that they
felt great shame and embarrassment using
a technology that's that's really
interesting right that's one of those
things where you look up you say well
there's something going on here that's
people don't talk about using their
technologies with great shame and
embarrassment a lot so I think that's
that was sort of one of those points
that sort of stood out um and one of the
other big things that we noticed was
that people were using the iPad for
content consumption right we expected
this right and we looked at the apps the
people used and people use Netflix
people use Epicurious people use all
these things but they're generally you
sit there and you consume stuff off the
tablet and people would often put
content creation aside for later so like
you know you get your emails you go
through your delete some of them you
might reply to a couple of them really
short you know a couple of words you
might say yeah I'll see you Thursday but
generally for anything more substantial
people did not use the tablet for
creating anything for creating email for
creating things like that there's a few
edge cases and I'm going to talk about
later because I think they're important
yeah because if you're creating
something and if I'm writing in my
notebook then I'm less likely to share
it with my cousin whereas if I'm just
reading a book
then I'm quite okay with doing it to my
person right it's an interesting
question well I think that's part of it
my guess is the biggest problem is how
slow it is to type on a on the screen
people are happy sharing that attacked
because they're not creating anything on
because they're not really oh so because
I
the magazine to catch a and I think all
of these a reasonable hypothesis that's
right kids we have a grand sense who are
you a keyboard laptop running with a
bang on that's it they're all exactly my
children's ability to make a laptop
computer do things that you never
thought were possible by banging on the
cue ball there's commands in Scott
there's like keyboard commands in Skype
that I never knew existed that
apparently make the computer blow up
because like so I think this is an
interim we're going to come back to this
one length about what's going on here
what's going on with the yeah what's
going on
I'm not sure I don't know sleep is the
answer I mean having mr. Tatem the
preliminary stuff I've seen the series
that people use Siri is great when
you're driving and you want to say you
want to sort of you know you're like
I'll bring up the map for this
particular address or something like
that and the examples and this is based
on me asking on Facebook about three
weeks ago hey does anybody use Siri and
these are the stories that I got back
whether people are going to start using
that more for voice input it'll be
interesting to see what we'll find out
some people really liked this idea
there's the distinction between a tablet
and a laptop so I mean if you look at
things like the Microsoft Surface which
has come out in the last couple of
months which is a tablet with a keyboard
attached right and when we were
suggesting those sort of concepts as
sort of a relatively obvious probe to
ask
some people hate on this guy Caleb was
like I think putting a physical keyboard
on an iPad is a Terrell idea it defeats
the point it's a totally new device
people who do that want it to be a
computer because they know what a
computer is ipads are different then
they're not computers they're something
different I think that's why for example
many people say I would use Siri all the
time and yet whew you don't very much I
think maybe you think people at home
tablets can be really really powerful I
think I think it's important to
recognize that things like Microsoft
Surface are a great first draft in that
space but they are not quite the sort of
the full there's a lot of possibilities
that we haven't explored right just as a
very simple edge case if we go back to
our typing on the couches you write the
the way that the surface works time
beyond the couch doesn't work very well
and you can think of other ways that you
could do that in other ways you can fit
configure that that could be much better
than that so I actually think keyboards
are interesting but then again I'm a
very text heavy person I read a lot I
write a lot my primary form of
intellectual output is in the form of
papers same as many people in this room
it's not clear that I'm the that I'm the
important part of this that I'm you know
I'm the kind of person for whom this
matters right um one of my favorite this
is a direct quote one of my favorite
experiences was talking to people about
that the apps that they used and we got
people to give us a tour of their of
their iPad and that was a sort of lovely
procedure to do to sort of sit down just
get people to sort of walk through
things and one of the things that people
told us was that the marketplace sucks
and we heard that over and over again it
was very hard to find the things that
people were looking for my favorite
example
was that somebody some one of these guys
who was quite technology savvy Jordan I
think we're calling him and Jordan I
remember Jordan saying his theory was
that Apple had made it so bad on purpose
so that other people would come up with
better algorithms so that you could get
an app that would be a better interface
to the store I said this to some people
at Apple the other day just to watch
them splutter it was it was kind of fun
so what what do people use right um
Netflix is the killer app right
everybody uses Netflix and we saw a
couple of interesting combinations so
Netflix was a great thing for to use
while you were doing something else
you're doing the laundry you've got the
iPad there you're cooking dinner you've
got iPad there we saw interesting things
like people watching iPad on the big
screen watching the sorry Netflix on the
big screen and then they'd have IMDB or
something open on the tablet on their
lap so you're like Oh wasn't she in
Buffy for a while and you know sort of
doing that IMDB ecosystem thing and I
think right now there are a very few
number of examples I can point to about
cross screen interactions where you've
got something on the big screen and
stuff on the small screen I can just
show you that everyone's very excited by
them and thinks they would be a good
idea where anyone to get around to doing
anything decent about them Heineken has
one for watching football matches I've
seen one or two other ones we didn't see
anyone who actually used any of these
apps and admittedly this was 18 months
ago so maybe things have been updated
since then yeah I see Nintendo did
something like this before
where you could have where there was a
there was an in the screen interaction
with that Nintendo Dreamcast well good
ideas come back you know I'm sure bill
Buxton invented it in 1983
these things keep going back at the
curious as fabulous as as Scott
mentioned I've had a long interest in
the kitchen and computers in the kitchen
and I'm very fond of putting you know
nice ads from Honeywell from 1967 with
kitchen computers in my talks
if the curious is nice because it just
does one thing and it does it really
well which is when you need to know what
to cook there it is this is one of the
few things that I changed my own
practices based on my research in that I
went out and I talked to people and all
the people we interviewed we're using
Epicurious and so now I use it in when
I'm cooking things and that's nice right
and it seems to work and it's kind of
nifty um FaceTime FaceTime people really
like FaceTime when it's Apple end to end
if you if you know that your
grandparents have a mac and you know
that you've got a macular kids then
people really like FaceTime some of you
might be familiar with a lot of work
that I did on how much Skype sucks and
Skype does over it's a little more
detailed than that but Facebook FaceTime
is a little more detailed is a little
more reliable um people like the form
factor of the full screen there was some
and there's not a keyboard sitting out
there for your kids to Wham on and then
make Skype do things that you never knew
were possible and Dropbox is interesting
Dropbox is particularly interesting
because there's no good way to move file
systems files on and off the iPad right
everybody talked about this as a
limitation and I think that there are
there is a whole other talk about why
Apple made those decisions and what
those imply for computing but people
found we kept hearing these stories
about Dropbox as a way that people would
get their stuff available to them we
also saw some really horrible hacks
because there were there weren't good
file systems one of my favorites was one
of the people we interviewed played
guitar in a church on Sunday so he was
in his church band he would use the the
web browser to go to sort of pieces of
sheet music on the web or tab on the web
he then take a screenshot of
the tab and then it would get saved to
the photos and then he would use the the
screenshot in it through through iPhoto
to play to to be able to play the music
and which is a horrible horrible hack
but it's a really interesting hack but
it does point to certain limitations
there all right
um and this ties into a bigger question
right which is about this role of the
iPad and about the role the iPad in sort
of working with other devices Dropbox is
a great example of something that works
really well across multiple devices
I think IMAP is another great example
but we sort of forget about because IMAP
works right you check your email from
one device you're going to work and use
your other work device you don't think
about the fact that it's that it's not
work that it's um that it's worked as
well as it has as a nice example think
about address book syncing right like
whether you replied someone on one
machine in it and the email address goes
to the right place on your machine
address book syncing still sucks it
still breaks regularly and yet we get
our email right so yeah things that
actually do work this is a wine that
said these are people whining and saying
what I just said all right now let's now
thank gives you an idea of some of the
data that we gathered and some of the
stories that came out of that and now I
want to sort of extrapolate and push
this forward and start making some stuff
up or drawing conclusions as as its more
nicely known and one day I went to these
three themes of comfortable computing
communal computing and there's thirst
third question of creation so let's go
back to this thing that people sit
comfortably when they using an iPad have
any of you read Lucy search man's human
machines reconfigurations a few so what
she basically did was take plans and
situated actions which was an earlier
book and then sort of wrapped a couple
of chapters around it saying oh this is
what I was really talking about and I'm
not sure I agree with her that this was
what she was talking about I should
emphasize I think both these books are
great books right but what she talks
about is the role of the body in
computing and the role in computing and
reconfiguring the body and how those two
go back and forth
and if you don't read the whole book
there's a really good article in
interactions this summer I think was
that in May June issue by Peter Wright
in which he manages its it's the best
article about bodies and computing
actually since your review article from
dis 2008 I think in which he says look
this is everything you need to know in
this book but ideally you'd read the
book but she talks about this way in
which bodies reconfigure the user and
the user reconfigures the computer and
so on and the tablet means that the user
uses it in a company place we kept
hearing people saying or will I killed
up with my iPad and I or we hear people
say things like well it's kind of like
my blankie was one of the phrases that
one of the informants used and people
talk about while I go you know I go from
the couch to my bedroom and and I'll
take my blankie with me in the form of
the iPad and okay fine you know nothing
exciting here but then there's this
interesting thing that it gets used for
these sort of comfortable uses and
people are using it for this sort of
social grooming for for checking with
friends on Facebook for doing little
things with Twitter and that's
interesting right now one way to do this
is say well use it's just the
affordances right it's just the form
factors it's crappy for doing other
things therefore people don't do other
things but I think there's something
more fundamental here about the role of
the body and the ways in which what your
body can do and the ways that the
affordances of the tablet suggests
certain things that are the right things
to do with it and I think that's kind of
interesting one of the things that we
realized in in writing this was that we
will look at we were writing this in in
an office same as as you might expect
and we realized that the the office
furniture spoke to a set of assumptions
about what kind of technology was in
there so the there was a certain depth
to the desk and in particular the corner
was sort of had extra space you could
put your big monitor in the corner of
the desk
alright that's kind of interesting and
we started to think as a thought
experiment what would happen if you know
we go went and sat down with the folks
at Steelcase and said alright
that's what computing looked like in the
80s and in the 90s what what would what
would be different if we had different
kinds of computing and how would that
change
the physical space right what would it
mean if you when you went to work for a
company instead of giving you a laptop
they gave you a tablet right how would
that change what your experiences were
with the technology so that's the thing
that comfortable computing and this is
something where I would love to hear
your expert advice on this because I
think it's an interesting question and I
think this ties into a set of work that
I've seen about the role in computing
the role of the body in computing I'm
sorry and yet it's one of these things
where I'm not sure where to take this
next is this just something where I
throw it out there
where as or is there other someplace we
can move this forward so that's the
first thing that I think is sort of
interesting out of this stuff the second
thing is I want to talk about this role
of communal computing now there's a lot
of work that's been done on having
multiple devices when thinking about the
stuff that aj brush and some of her team
did up at stanford sorry did up at
redmond at microsoft research on family
accounts on computers because this
question of how you manage multiple
people using a single device is one that
comes up again and again and again and
thinking about things like what are the
right levels of passwords earlier on we
were talking about things that people
want to keep private as is in the
context of discussion about finance and
income and things like that and so
people want to you know generally people
don't want to share what their financial
state is like you might share specific
things like oh well I'm thinking about
investing in in solar energy stocks
right and people have that discussion
but there's a limit to how much
financial information people want to
share people care about their medical
records right people might be willing to
say oh well I have this particular
problem I hurt my leg or something but
people are often little cagey about
theirs their medical information and
then there's porn sex and porn right
like it's it's this ubiquitous thing
that we don't talk about we don't talk
about a lot in HCI and arguably well
except for me
arguably we should talk more about it
but this is sort of another thing that
gets used and sort of thinking about
these private areas within computing I
think that the right way to handle that
and the flip side of this is saying well
it would actually be very convenient to
be able to walk up to a computer and say
oh here's a computer I want to use a web
browser right what are the sort of
lowest levels that you can make
accessible to people and that you maybe
should make it
to people so this ties into this
question of families using devices
everyone has seen these systems that
various people have built over time
where you have you have a tablet
computer on a fridge right I did this
I'm sorry
I'd like to apologize in public but when
one of the times when you put a five
tablet computer on our fridges people
try and replicate the functionality that
fridge spaces had before
fridges are very good for organizing
families right Alex Taylor and Laurel
Swan at Microsoft Research Cambridge
have done some fabulous fabulous stuff
on this but one of the problems is that
when you get engineers to design this
thing they say well all right we're
gonna have this system we're just kind
of a very simple four digit PIN number
that people can use to put it in to gain
access to the system and then we'll have
a different one for the parents to use
so they have higher levels of social of
access like well but this isn't actually
what the problem right like this is not
generally you know if you go over to
someone's house and they have a calendar
up on the up on the fridge you don't go
and write stuff in you know you don't
add stuff to this well I do actually add
stuff to people shopping lists now but I
try and add stuff that's ridiculous
enough that it's pretty clear they
shouldn't actually buy it you know
barrel of monkeys kind of thing but it's
precisely because it's a social
transgression that it becomes an
interesting thing to do at parties
that's my excuse anyway but thinking
about the social structures around
sharing information because generally
families want to know what you know one
don't want to have barriers between
barriers to actually using devices right
if you've got younger kids you do it you
may actually want to know what your what
your kids are doing and you may well
want to be reading their email but
thinking about the ways in which this
question of multiple people using single
devices it's a nice way to sort of push
these these ideas forward and the second
thing that I want to talk about in that
context is this idea of single users do
not have single identities and this is
sort of an ongoing fight that I feel
like we're having as a society right now
it's not at all clear to me that
everyone should have a single identity
they use for everything so I want to do
a poll because I you're a nice sample
audience for this how many of you have a
Facebook account all right put your
hands down how many of you have more
than one Facebook account including ones
you use for joke purposes it's less than
I thought I'm a little disappointed with
my own my own project gusty nation so
the studies that I've seen particularly
if you look at younger crowds people
have multiple accounts I have three I
have my own one I have a character I
invented purely for playing farmville
called Jo farmer and then I have a
French québécois DJ called DJ
jean-claude Rock I must admit I haven't
used for a while but was pretty fun
while I well I did here's a list of
websites that I came up with that people
have to have some login form a will
value some login and you can see that
these different websites you may have
very good reasons why you don't want
your identities being crossed being on
all of these if you're writing
fanfiction if you're checking into
places all the time if you're a heavy
frequent flyer if you're trying to save
money if your tape putting up photos
FetLife is a fabulous example fetlife is
a social network for people interested
in sex basically it's it's reasonably
large its heavily trafficked lots of
people use it and it's a perfect example
where people want to have a different
identity on fetlife than they do that is
not linkable to their professional lives
and i think there's a lot of questions
here about this role of multiple
identities and how you can tie this this
people having multiple identities into
this question of multiple people using
single devices yeah it was back a few
years ago when there was single computer
for a family it was just as communal
and I think it's related obviously I
think the ways in which it has become a
problem have changed somewhat one of the
things that in in that single computer /
/ / families story is that you don't
have as much of this notion of identity
on the Internet
all right and you were those problems
you know there were people posting on
Usenet no doubt and saying oh well I'm
posting on Usenet and in you know
whatever old model airplanes but my son
keeps supposed to you know transformers
and but you know it's not like these are
these are totally new problems but I
think the facility
very easy way in which we can sit you
know you can all be sitting there in
front of the television and pass a
tablet around between you makes these
come to the forefront more so it's not
that I think it's a fundamentally
different question I would probably say
it's probably more of a problem than it
was but I think it's very much related
and if you I mean even if you go back to
some of the early stuff on this like
venkatesh 1996 there's an article in me
in the ACM talking about what people do
with computers in the home in the
communications of the ACM and he talks
about this as being one of the issues
that comes up but it's remarkable that
we haven't solved it right that it's
still an issue that we're talking about
so until my third thing here which is
this idea of models of creation right so
here's the easy thing and this is I kind
of think of this with all due respect to
my various colleagues as being this is
the Apple story right
tablets are for consuming media right
you can go onto onto iTunes and you can
download the best content in the world
you can look at great videos you can
play some games that other people have
written if you get if you get a computer
like a real computer not like a tablet
computer like a real computer then you
too could write stuff for tablets but
tablets are devices for consumption and
you can see that that's sort of a place
that we could go and say okay that's
fine that's that's what happens right
but I think and this is kind of a
political thing more than anything else
I think I believe in some political and
moral istic way that there is something
right about
Computers being used for for concern for
creation and not just for consumption
and I come from a reasonably long life
it was a reasonably long line of people
going back to a computer live I'm
thinking of right saying you know there
is actually sort of a moral question
here and so what's the kind of creation
that we are seeing with a tablet right
and that's the that's what I want to go
into some of what we're seeing is
curation and that's what I want to spend
a bunch of time on and some of it is a
simple change that would no longer talk
about text but we're talking about video
so here's a video I'd like to show you
see if this works maybe this was created
by Jim Jim is a high school teacher in
London and he created this on his lunch
hour literally on the Sunday lunch hour
using an iPad to write so he's doing a
little bit of stop-motion animation is
putting some stuff together he's putting
some music in there there's a little bit
of background stuff
lovely that's Jim he pretty much looks
like that so that's kind of interesting
right that's a kind of creation that so
is that was made entirely on an iPad
that wasn't made entirely on a tablet
and okay just some degree that's anomaly
but there's some other things that we're
starting to see and a lot of it starts
to look like this that you can't see now
you've got - way lovely and that's the
role of curation and mashup in creating
new stuff here we have a picture and
then someone has added a caption to it
right creating a new object 4chan spends
an awful lot of time doing things
precisely like this right whether it's
people taking some existing mean whether
it's creating new memes this idea that
you can create new things by jamming
stuff together is something that's been
very popular for like the 20th
throughout the 20th century right you
can go back to to John Hartfield in the
first half of the 20th century can go
around to all these people doing collage
right and this way in which this this
process of ongoing taking existing
things changing them adding commentary
to them working with them juxtaposing
different things selecting certain
things to put next to other things
recirculating back in I think is a
powerful form of creation and I think
it's easy to dismiss it because you know
the highest form of the art is a duck
shouting at people right and yet there's
something interesting it's like
dismissing rap music because they don't
use they don't play guitars they're just
using records and they're just using
samples they're not actually musicians
therefore right and I think there's
something that's more interesting that's
going on here Twitter I think is another
nice example here
lots of people use Twitter and they say
things on Twitter an awful lot of people
are using Twitter in this curatorial way
in which they get a whole bunch of stuff
in and when they see something
interesting they retweet it out to their
followers possibly with this kind of
commentary right and that's the kind of
function that is enabled on a tablet
it's not obviously only happening on
tablets but it's enabled on a tablet
Pinterest is another nice example right
of anyone as they're able to use
so-called yet social sorry social and
you don't even work for Microsoft or
what were you working for Microsoft when
you it's a Microsoft social network it
basically enables you to doing it lets
you do sort of Pinterest collages very
easily and very much in this vein so
once this process looked like right and
there's that we have we gathered a whole
bunch of examples of this and they all
end up fitting into roughly this this
system right you collect a whole bunch
of stuff together you curate it right
you pick the stuff that you think is
important you discard the stuff that's
not important
you collage things together right you're
creating new things by combining things
that you keep you comment on it and that
may be part of the of the collage
process right I mean you can definitely
read the the the duck shouting as being
part of the sort of combining these two
in this juxtaposition and then you
recirculate it right it comes circulated
back out to the mid to the networks that
you saw this stuff come in and this
again this ties in to this sort of very
20th century tradition about
reappropriation or even pulling stuff
together and I think this is a place
that I'm seeing work in I'm seeing this
kind of creation happening in tablets so
I want to be careful about that because
obviously this is not all happening on
tablets right this is not only happening
on tablets and I'm not saying that
everything that you see on Pinterest and
Twitter and 4chan or whatever is created
on tablets far from it right but there's
something interesting that's going on
here right about what the affordances
are there's something lovely about
sorting photos when you can when you can
drag them around on a screen there's a
reason that that every touch interaction
video well for as long as Bill Buxton
has been doing them
involves people rotating photographs so
then making them bigger right it's a
very nice thing to be able to do that
sort of sort that sort of video work
they're sort of photograph work it's a
nice interface for it so I retain a
certain degree of cynicism around this
particular set of conclusions but I do
think it's kind of interesting so I want
to wrap up and I'm deliberately tried to
keep this short because I'd like to have
a discussion with all of you about these
particular areas I think thinking of
tablets as a tool to think through the
future of computing gets really
interesting right and I think there are
three particular areas that that point
directions for the future that I think
are worth spending some time thinking
about first is this idea of comfortable
computing right taking the actions of
the body seriously in the ways that
people's bodies are configured changes
that the things that they do online and
things that the changes the things that
they do with the computer the second is
this role of communal computing right
and thinking really about what it means
to have multiple identities on any given
device and multiple identities for a
single for single people and for
multiple people using device and third
this new kinds of creation right if we
are seeing more and more tablets if we
aren't going away from the standard
thing for the last 120 years as I mean
when it's time to create something you
sit down at a keyboard right and this is
what Mark Twain did like a hundred years
ago was like alright I'm gonna write
this thing called Huckleberry Finn so he
sat down in front of the keyboard of his
Remington and he wrote a book on it
right 120 years when we wanted to create
things people have sat down and done
that obviously there been other ways to
create but it has been an absolutely
dominant form of creation in our world
for the for quite some time and what
happens if the dominant computing
devices that are dominant tools that are
around no longer have keyboards right
and that gets very interesting and I
think it suggests that there may be we
may be finally seeing these things that
people like Bill Mitchell have predicted
for a while books like the the rise of
the image and the fall of the word are
we going to see this this thing that we
do so well which is rights and papers
get them published and other people read
them and then they write some other
papers isn't that gonna go away probably
not but are there ways in which that's
going to change and ways which the
dominant modes of creation so I think
these are interesting questions I don't
know the answers thank you very much for
listening
yeah actually to narrow
I mean people may not be looking at I
practice that I caught me of creation of
consumption it could be that they're
using it for entirely new dishes like
communicating so when I think of iPad it
seems like more and more it's it's at
least do the uploads it seems like it's
a FaceTime device rather than you know
creation of communication consumption
device so I wonder just you know
dichotomizing it is too narrow
absolutely amazing it is obviously to
now however if there are limitations on
that communication that are happening
because of the device so if for example
you write me a nice long newsy email
about the stuff that you've been doing
and I look at my device and I'm like oh
well I can't reply to this on on this
tablet I've got to go to some other
device then I think you're gonna have an
impact based on those affordances but
maybe what you're going to have as me
not sending an uzi even but instead
having a face man animation maybe and I
mean but then I would since I see this
discussion forms are I think that the
boat is telling me there was someone
else
earlier on about Siri and whether this
was done pre or post Siri and this was
pre Siri and I think the answer is we
don't know I feel like people have sat
up in this place in this room for 20
years and said well the good really soon
now we're gonna have really good voice
control for stuff right and
I mean and I think we're gonna start to
see those and you're already seeing
these education right I mean Dragon
Dictate for people who have RSI for
example is something that we've seen
happening and yet the functionality is
still such that if you if you have an
alternative and this may be just that
our systems have not been developed well
enough to really respond to this typing
is still better than dictating I mean I
know every so often when when my when my
wrists get particularly bad and I go
back to using the dictating God it's
annoying
I mean I'll manage it for a review or to
for some reason reviews are always the
time which my wrists break probably
psychological but either but it's
frustrating right so yes I'd love to
believe that it's going to happen
um one of the things I've done a couple
of times when he was coaching so when
you were teaching 147 I think 247 and I
suggested to the group that I was doing
is in a only slightly unethical way but
instead of sending email for the next
week they should just try sending each
other video and they didn't do it they
would come closer I'm yet to persuade
anybody to do this if anyone wants to do
an experiment I'd love to in which you
you and a small group commit to only
communicating using audio and video
whether there's some transcription and
there is another question but it's
remarkably hard to admit to to do yeah
did you see when I think about my iPad
usage the thing I use the most is
neither consumption for creation it's
using it as like the shared interface
for all the other devices I use it to
control the music in our house I used it
as a remote for the TV it was
interesting to not see that come up even
though that's really built in like an
iTunes that's like a for Apple feature
so I educate that's an aspect that we
would having these interviews 18 months
ago and people had not yet got to that
stage of of using it a lot and I believe
it didn't really work until iTunes 10 is
that correct
oh is that something like that I think
there were one or two people who had
talked about that and that was a theme
that came up one of the families that
the people we talked to had oh I can't
remember done one of those things read
instrumented his whole house and so we
could open his curtains from the bed
using the mumble x10 mumble but it
basically didn't work and his wife hated
it like it was one of those stories but
I mean I think those basic things
turning music off and on sharing screens
that sort of question I think we're
gonna see more and more of that they end
up being relatively brief interactions
though I mean I'm always a little
nervous about ways of counting things
that count duration because as being
sort of what people want to do because
on that basis we would want to spend our
time on hold on 800 numbers and I mean
if you look at if you're doing an
analysis of how people use telephones
the longest duration is calling customer
support that's how you have 45 minutes
now and half cologne conversations but
those are not what we really like doing
that being said if all you're doing is
turning volume up and down a bit you're
skipping over call me maybe because you
heard it six times yesterday there's a
limit to how much that interaction that
is but I think a lot of that's just not
frankly there's a space between data and
writing and giving talks about things
like that we could do follow-up the more
elective dimension okay
just curious how you react to criticism
of that last point you have up there
which says that creation through
collections cards etc is inherently
shallow as opposed to mark twain sitting
at the typewriter and really thinking
about a whole model of it it's bad
Society for us to be going that
direction yeah oh my go back to the rent
music thing right I think there are it's
delicate because you find yourself
defending wall cat is really quickly
prejudice and I think lost cats can be
pretty funny but do I think that they
sort of compared to Huck Finn probably
not right
I think it's precisely because I care
about that question that I want to ask
this right it's because I worry about
devices that make a fundamental
distinction between author and
consumption and consumer right let's say
this is a device for consumption you
need to spend more money if you want to
create
things and that worries me as a pattern
which is why I want to have that
conversation I think there are devices
there are things that you can create
through mash up through reference
through collage that really can be very
sophisticated pieces of pieces of of
culture right you look at the sort of
things that people are doing with
machinima and they are they may or may
not be the greatest pieces of art that
humankind has ever produced but if you
put them up next to whatever is you know
on fox news tonight of on the Fox
channel tonight at 8 o'clock
they're pretty comparative pieces of
creation right so I'm not sure I agree
that what's produced is necessarily as
bad obviously if a lot of stuff is
produced you know you're going to have a
power-law right a lot of it is not going
to be very good but I think there is
absolutely the potential for really good
stuff and there are particular examples
we can point to with things that I think
have been successful does that answer
the question you're actually getting
people to create the cars moment to riff
on some image macro or to comment on
someone's Facebook post that you're
you're getting the creation out of
people who would not otherwise create
sure it's not really maybe you can yeah
and I think I mean I think your work
before Chan is a really nice sort of
example of looking in that process that
people so maybe you start off like
commenting low on someone else's lolcat
and then from there you say well okay
now I'm going to create my own wall cat
using this existing image macro and now
I'm going to upload a photo that I think
would make a good one and I'm going to
edit the photo so that it looks like a
particular set of things and I think
there's a path to creation and we need
to be reasonably agnostic about this and
and and and say well okay the more ways
that we can have these opportunities for
creation it's probably a good thing for
society at the same time I don't claim I
think this is weakest this is weak
signals right but I think it's weak
signals that I'm seeing in a lot of
different places
I remember at some point looking at
like it was the all the single ladies
that song called all the single ladies
single ladies maybe I'll look at Terry
because he huge Rihanna anyway if you're
gonna look for single ladies on YouTube
there are in the millions of people who
are doing their who had done their own
versions of the dance and uploaded them
and they are dancing you know the same
way that you know when you were a kid
you know you sort of went up in front of
the mirror with a hairbrush and you know
saying I don't know Bon Jovi Beyonce
Beyonce it's true young man Frank
Sinatra and now you know and yeah okay
maybe that stuff now ends up on YouTube
right and I think that's kind of an
interesting phenomenon and one that kind
of gives me a bit of hope right like you
know yes here's some you know relatively
mass-produced piece of song but here's
thirty-five million nine hundred nine
people who care about this enough to go
and do their own version and put that up
there and you know when you see
three-year-olds dancing two single
ladies and they're really enjoying it
and they're like enjoying the sensation
of moving their bodies and the music
like that's great right so I think there
is something here and I think getting
away from these notions of what
constitutes sort of you know the right
to create and and democratization that
gets really interesting
you know how the business people yeah no
but you know these other media these are
the ways of creating actually in that
day you'll be part of compensate because
they're putting the visual stuff
together I know that's something I find
personally very hard I hate video I hate
watching video I find it it takes so
long as mentioned you know I found a way
that I could watch YouTube videos twice
as fast so it didn't take as long I I
really don't like video at all but I can
appreciate there's something here for
other people right I love one of the
reasons I like reading is because I can
do it very very fast I can skim things
very very quickly weather will have more
opportunities for sort of crossover and
one of the lessons I learned at Nokia
was that when I need it when I when I
found something out I needed to tell the
story in three different ways
I would I would write a paper about it
because that was how I understood it I
would make a PowerPoint deck which had
slides which looked like other Nokia
slides so that people could steal the
slides and use them in their deck and
ideally I'd make a short video as well
that would go on sort of the internal
YouTube for sharing so the people who
liked video would then watch it but
there was this realization that you
needed to put information out in all
three of these forms depending on who
was going to listen to it really the
sense that what tires all of these three
things specifically for the it's a very
shallow level of commitment in addition
to a shell my book creation if I lose my
and this made me just my own case but if
I lose my ipod there's not much on it
that I would feel at having lost whereas
if I lost my laptop I would just be like
a lot of data would be gone and through
Junko I don't know
but do you see if you you know this
future sort of creation model being a
lot more deeper in that in which case
sort of this communal computing is going
to be more critical because if I look at
my iPad and I say here's my iPad what
would I want you to not see it would
probably be just Facebook and email the
rest would be for communal consumption I
wonder that if there's not two things
that are going on here at orthogonal and
what is this question of losing
information right and one of the stories
that I'm hearing increasingly about
things like Dropbox things like Dropbox
things like IMAP again presumably iCloud
even things like Gmail right is the idea
that you the whole Chromebook is based
on the theory that you can't do stuff
right if things are up in Google Docs
they're up in Google Docs you get in
from another computer so I think that's
a trend that I see happening more and
more and more right the idea that you
have single things on single devices
that might die I think will be going
away one of the reasons that were that
we're seeing such if you go to any
conference and you someone mentions Big
Data and they show you a graph that
looks like this right one of the reasons
it looks like this and okay middlee not
like that
it's because people are duplicating
things I know it Yahoo we basically
everything is copied three times right
like any given thing that's up on a
server is on three different things and
that's pretty standard across the
industry lots of people do that so I
think there there is a question about
data the data security which i think is
not really the important one that you're
asking I think the one I think is more
interesting is about this role of
creation right and whether there are
ways to do shallow and deeper kinds of
creation that maintain that and I wonder
if that's really a distinction right I
mean if if everything if I if I could
very easily save my state in one place
and go and pick up another computer and
when I walk up it I identified me with
verified deals creepy face recognition
and I start off exactly where I was
watching single ladies videos on YouTube
or whatever it was I mean I think I I
think
not an intrinsic link between those two
I'm not convinced that there is any
particular reason that you need to do
only deep creation or any shadow
creation on any particular device
fair enough is a exploration two of you
like brought paper scissors to see you
guys so this study that was like one I
pad per household did anyone have more
than one I've had and the question how
does that change things how does that
talk to you about their family
goodbye multi-device interactions in
collaboration so super good question I
believe mostly they helped me had one
iPad per household I think there was
what there was at least one or two nicer
and I'd have to go back and check my
notes to be sure there was at least one
household in which they each had an iPad
but I think one of them left it at work
and did stuff with it there I mean one
of these I haven't talked about in this
talk a lot is about sort of professional
uses of iPads because we did see some of
those people have bought styluses for
their iPads people who had they were
using them for checking people into
clinics because they were sort of these
devices very easy to hand out to people
so there were certain things we saw with
multiple iPads I don't think any of the
homes that we talked to had multiple
iPads lying around home we could do
another poll my last poll failed
miserably so let's see okay so hands up
if you have hands up if you have an iPad
family say in your house right I would
say like 75% something like that
hands up if you have another non iPad
tablet some I would say I should point
out that we actually went out looking
for tablets and what we found were iPads
now that might be a little bit different
but back then that was very clearly
place and hands up if you have more than
one iPad in your house so a few but not
a great number a great number
of course you know I saw some of the
editor students where you have fairly
independent people living in the same
house yeah yeah then is that would you
say that characterizes your experience
that you've got on your roommate has
woman
there's definitely ownership I mean I
don't actually own one night my wife
owns wine and I get to use it if I'm
good
well then I have things like you know I
have a grouse to cook well exactly
except I could you know let's go to get
those recipes from somehow
did you have a follow up what was that
look yeah so what sort of so the only
really good device device thing we saw
with the iPad was there's a Scrabble
game that you can get where the Scrabble
board is the iPad or then you can use
your iPhones which is a lovely little
concept right the turns out it's I I
don't know I'm not sure it was a smash
hit but it's a lovely idea I mean I want
it to work right and I think that we you
is another nice example of thinking
about these kind of like device device
interactions I think this is the thing
that you're gonna start to see a lot of
work done on this I know folks at
Samsung they're working on this I know
that people have Nokia have been talking
about it I know people at Yahoo we're
talking about it probably people at
Microsoft are talking about it
I think everyone's realized that this is
sort of the obvious thing that's gonna
happen next I still haven't found a
really good story about why there's got
to be some right and I mean I you know
the Scrabble thing is nice because you
have a reason to keep part of the
display private and part of it public
you want a central place for whom for
interaction but I'm still waiting I'm
still waiting for a really sort of
compelling story that we can all be we
can all be like yeah don't you love
playing multi device interaction time
all right get away from my cousin
creational consumption
what were your thoughts on like
designing tablets on the world tablets
as I accessible your bike sitting it's
so much for example like a few girl back
I read an article where a blind person
was using an iPhone and the item it had
an app that will tell you like black
color like it was pointing it and that
person had like revelations about and
got like some sense of what color
actually meant right and so how do you
things have that's good like help people
making blind people they might be
already them probably redesign
interactions so again that's one of
those questions for which the answer is
a whole talk I went and talked to we
have a guy called Alan Blackwell yeah
Blackwell what's his name Brightman
thank you who does accessibility stuff
at Yahoo and we were talking about this
particular issue iPhones when they came
out were absolutely dreadful for blind
people like they were nearly completely
unusable and it was very clear that they
were that Apple was basically gonna get
the ass sued off them for a DEA reasons
and then they very quickly came out with
a remarkably good interface for telling
you what's under your finger right now
that you're pointing to tablets
similarly kind of interesting they can
be there are I think there are
opportunities there I'm not convinced
totally by the it's not clear to me that
telling a blind person that what you're
pointing at now is red is gonna it's not
clear to me what that tells them like
like what do they know now they know
that red and there's red next to green
okay like like brought your phone up
with them like at night alright sunrise
and then they knew that when the Sun was
bright and they would I expect here in
this color I said it was more like they
know a bit more about this routings
rather and it's a useful app in its
interests over the weekend now yeah I
mean spoken descriptions of what what
what what is on photos like blind
photography is actually quite a big
thing for blind people like like in it
and it's sort of becoming more and more
prevalent at the same time I'm not
convinced that there's a sort of
fundamental difference with tablets that
changes that do you think there is one
holy mic interesting way in which you
might use like such devices yeah and
because like touch devices and these
tablets are facing like specks of glass
and it's like highly visual and this
seems to like be good forward like most
people but worse for some no it's a good
question I don't ask a point I see what
they say this is an area I'm very
conscious of my of my lack of expertise
at the same time knowing certain
interaction paradigms can actually make
things much easier when I was working on
smart kitchens at the Media Lab with
Wendy Joo in fact she designed this very
nice interface which was projected down
onto a table and you could sort of touch
different things and this guy came by he
was a professor at Louisiana State
University who was blind and I remember
talking about him with this device I was
like well you know this is a very visual
interface that's gotta suck for you he
said out but if I know that I can stand
here if I know that when I come to the
corner and I find the corner and I can
stand there and then I have an interface
in front of me that's actually a really
powerful point right to know that you
have those kind of affordances that are
built-in so he was actually far more of
a fan of it than I thought he was going
to be yes yeah so my favorite part about
the movie avatar
they're all people aside was the guy is
in a lab and it's got a desktop and it's
got violent
and he picks up his tablet and it puts
his hand on desktop screen and moves it
over to his tablet and the whole display
Versa take his entire session right
there that's what I want when that
happens like that has implications for
the composing consuming like you're just
moving your workflow even your workflow
to couch remove your floating a car you
move your workflow to the Train and it
also has communal community or instead
of saying look at this picture you say
look at my workflow like maybe maybe
more and work that at home
do you see that as complementing this or
there entirely new things that will
happen what's that well I mean the one
question is why you need to bother doing
this right right right
why you don't bring out the temas and
say oh here's what I was doing
right right so I mean there was
something to be said for for explicit
interaction at some point but I think I
mean this goes back to this question
multiple identities right in the idea
that things follow you around and as
mentioned we're good at getting our
files through Dropbox to follow us
around we're good at getting our mail
through I'm out to follow us around I've
seen work presented at Kai Jacob bhadram
Bodrum maybe I think he had something
Kai 2009 about a system that would be
that was like that for windows logon and
or you go up it automatically saves
state in some reasonably smart kind of
way there projectors you take a picture
of your laptop same apps and a transpose
your Android phone so it's a horrible
hat why doesn't your phone just know
already zero click interface
it might be looking up some have been
looking up there a map up on my my home
computer so I know that my colleagues
Tim son and some other folks did this a
Nokia way you you bring out your phone
and it would automatically sync on your
computer
okay that's nice and if you can then it
would be nice to be able to do that with
with with other things other than
webpages right you know I have a very
wrinkled stanford map which tells me
which I use I've been using for three or
four years now it has all these
buildings that are missing because
because they didn't exist three or four
years ago god I wish I could have a
decent map of that on my phone I'm still
having found one so I still cut around
this little piece of paper I don't knows
where I can get more any more questions
for the communit imputing thing I any
wonder whether what you're looking for
is visibility rather than security so I
mean if I get an iPad just like you
don't go and write appointments um
somebody else's fridge I'm not going to
look at your emails just because I got
your iPad so I wonder all you really
need to design for there is just making
private things less visible rather than
creating security mechanisms in order to
ensure that that is the case so I'm a
huge fan of not having security
mechanisms that social and I wonder if
it's not even a case of making it less
visible or more about making building
devices that are aware right so even if
you have Safari and you know that this
is my set of tabs that I was using last
time right and maybe that's on the page
that's labeled this is Joe Fisher's page
right but when you turn on your you're
given a page that anyone can use right
click here and you can get your web
browser click here you can get your
email right there's no particular reason
why that shouldn't be possible and being
able to pick up a device maybe you
authenticate with your phone people love
authenticating with phones right I mean
everyone in nokia believes everyone
wanted authenticate with their phone and
I go like that
and then I can use my my use the screen
I can use all the functionality there
and then when I go away it's not left on
there right like if you actually sort of
put your email on someone else's device
it's a it's a hefty level of commitment
that's like you do that way after you've
moved in and shared toothbrushes you
know I like that I'm not sure quite I'm
ready for that right but thinking about
those sort of lightweight ways but all
of these ball back to this question
thinking about identity right and
thinking about the right ways to
transfer identity between different
devices and play with alright I think we
should finish up
you